tu as remarqué
le bouddhisme ne s'apprend pas dans les
prisons non c'est vrai et oui cette
semaine encore on a découvert en
banlieue une cellule dormante de
chrétiens fanatiques qui agressaient des
habitants dans les cages d'escaliers en
leur tendant à tour de rôle leur joue
droite puis leur joue gauche
il faut que cela cesse que le climat
s'apaise et que les communautés retourne
ce lyncher entre elles
n'ont alors pas une semaine sans que
l'islamisme ne fasse la une dernière
fois que j'allume ma télé je tombe sur
un imam fou en train de prêcher en fait
c'est diam's
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non mais je ne veux pas la critiquer moi
je la préfère musulmane que rappeuse
alors le terroriste s'appelait jérémy
louis sydney bah moi je le comprends le
type avec un nom pareil il vaut mieux se
convertir et s'appelait chérif à l'islam
quoi
louis sydney moi ça me déstabilise comme
non c'est pas si c'est un autre style
qui organise des rencontres de tuning ou
un chanteur de zouk
comme d'habitude à tout ce cirque avec
l'interpellation alors la police qui est
choquée que le type les attendent avec
un flingue eux
c'est un terroriste
il arrive déguisé en robocop et de
l'autre côté ils s'attendent à quoi je
dire le le mec qui va les attendre avec
une [ __ ] à mouches tu veux il ouvre
la porte il sert des loukoums et du thé
[Applaudissements]
or
aucune logique alors comme la famille du
gat qui porte plainte contre les flics
pour homicide volontaire
encore heureux que c'est volontaire
alors si même les flics se mettent à
tirer au hasard
ça ils auraient dû faire quoi arriver à
pardon quand le trucider sans faire
exprès
jeter un filet de pêche away ou demander
le carnet de correspondance sait pas
on se marche sur la tête en forcément
tout la réaction des voisins le truc la
réaction habituelle
non mais c'était quelqu'un de très
gentil
c'était quelqu'un de très gentil en
général c'est comme ça commence toutes
les histoires dans faites entrer
l'accusé
[Musique]
et un mec t'es gentil et serviable il
nous disait bonjour
sans déconner
évidemment le gars et veut monter des
homicides au tnt il valait prévenir tout
le monde quant à dire ouais bon jour je
suis un fou furieux quand j'ai des
posters ben laden la maison je vais tous
vous égorger mais surtout vous le dites
parce que sinon je suis dans la merde
comment
tout ça pour faire quoi alors c'est ça
le plus dramatique tout ça pour faire
quoi jeter une bombe dans une épicerie
il n'y a pas que l'économie qui souffre
d'un manque de compétitivité le
terrorisme aussi
il paraît qu'elle n'était pas tout seul
c'est vrai que quand on a autant
d'intelligence serait dommage pas la
partager
c'était tout un réseau télé mec qui
cogite des mois ils échafaudent des
plans tout ça pour [ __ ] en l'air une
supérette
se désole serment ou d'intégration
au en corse en une nuit trompeter une
dizaine de centres leclerc sans faire un
mort
[Applaudissements]
pas peu dire ce qu'on veut mais les
corses ils bouffent peut-être du port
mais au moins ils sont efficaces
alors évidemment les convertis sont les
plus radicaux ça c'est normal je connais
un ami qui était musulman il s'est
converti au christianisme
à force d'aller à la messe il est devenu
alcoolique c'est c'est comme les
comédiens qui se lancent ils en font
toujours trop toit pour les castings et
rien j'exige n'existe plus après les
fonds plus belle la vie
et je vous parle pas de ceux qui
finissent pitre dans des talk shows
genre canal+ c'est la honte absolue
alors évidemment chacun réagit président
du crif
l'islamisme c'est le nouveau nazisme
elle ferait bien de revoir ses
classiques quoi pour un juif au 21ème
siècle ne pas distinguer le nazisme
non mais c'est pas la même chose les
nazis avaient wagner les islamistes ils
ont diam's
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'à 12 miles douleur et les mille et
une nuits de cristal en fin
politique faut quand même en parler un
peu couverture du point dsk parle
ce que moi je pensais que lui faisait
que
c'est bizarre ce mec
heureusement que d'autres sont là pour
prendre la relève alors j'ai vu la une
de l'express
ces femmes qui gâchent la vie quoi ces
socialistes et don juan quoi
international merkel parti en grèce en
ce moment dramatique les allemands n'ont
plus d'argent si même la chancelière est
obligé de partir là-bas hors saison
tu as vu l'accueil de fous moi je
comprends qu'elle se fasse siffler les
tipis sont à fond ils ont sorti les
drapeaux à croix gammée une nana de la
cd ou qui débarque au les mecs sont
déçus quoi il s'attendait un truc un peu
plus viril fois tu vois ce que je veux
dire quoi bon
faits divers alors je peux pas parler
ses divers sans parler de marseille
corruption à la bac on en parle beaucoup
on parle beaucoup trop
travaillé à la bac c'est peut-être une
des rares occasions pour un flic d'être
associé à un diplôme
alors à marseille ils ont découvert une
nana qui avait une crèche clandestine
ça c'est toute la différence entre les
chinois et les français quoi les chinois
quand il travaille aux blacks qu'ils
ouvraient l'entreprise les français un
service public
et alors est ce qu a aussi des bonnes
nouvelles c'est dur à trouver là est
allé cette photo d'un acteur porno gay
qui pose devant auschwitz je me souhaite
bonne chance pour monter son dossier
d'adoption
[Applaudissements]
alors est pas belle la vie et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus